welcome to M coding I'm James Murphy
let's talk about asynchronous
programming in Python I'll show you the
basic async await syntax as well as the
built-in async IO library then we'll get
into the good stuff writing a web
crawler alright let's jump into the code
I claim that you already understand
asynchronous programming suppose today
we've got three things we need to do
we're waiting on our Amazon package to
arrive we need to do our laundry and
we're also baking a cake so do we just
Loop over those tasks and do them one
after another according to this first we
should spend all day waiting for our
package to arrive only after it arrives
should we start our laundry and then we
should sit and wait for our laundry to
finish after our laundry finishes we
start baking the cake and watch it in
the oven until it's done nothing wrong
with a lazy Saturday if that's the way
that you want to do things but at the
very least you probably recognize that
things could be done more efficiently
why not just order your package then
immediately put your laundry in then
immediately put the cake in all you're
doing is waiting why not just wait for
all three at the same time
well that's exactly the fundamental idea
behind asynchronous programming just
like in real life there are some tasks
in programming that are primarily made
up of waiting for something to finish
happening these would typically be
things like waiting on a file to finish
writing to disk or waiting on packets
from the network it doesn't matter
whether using python or C you can't make
facebook.com respond any faster you just
have to wait and that's what async IO is
all about if you're waiting on a bunch
of things you can wait on all of them at
the same time
all right so how do we do it in Python
take any function that might need to
wait on something and slap an async on
there for us that's do work and then we
also have to mark main async because we
want to do work in Main
do work and Main are now co-routine
functions unlike a normal function when
you call a CO routine function it
doesn't run the function instead calling
a co-routine function an async def
function returns a co-routine which you
can think of as a very lightweight task
but the whole point of async is that we
don't just want to immediately run every
task that we come up with
so calling main down here just creates
this main task but it doesn't run it use
asyncio.run to start the very first
co-routine
this starts the event Loop which is in
charge of actually running our
co-routines
here we're calling do work but remember
this just creates a CO routine it
doesn't run it if we run the code we see
a warning saying the do work was never
awaited if you ever see this error it
probably means you forgot to write a
weight a weight means wait here until
this thing is done pausing the current
task if necessary async and python is
purely Cooperative you have to opt in
and participate in order to see the
gains
here we're still using time.sleep which
is not an async function python will not
pause and let someone else work just
because this is sleeping the only time
you might pause and let something else
run is when you await it so replace
time.sleep with asyncio.sleep and don't
forget to await it this is a kind of
silly example because I could of course
just delete the Sleep altogether but
remember here async IO is usually about
waiting on iO so mentally replace this
with writing to disk or waiting on
packets from the network
stay tuned for the web crawler to see a
real use case in any case we run the
thing again and
it still took three seconds
and that's because of these lines here
remember a weight means to wait here
until this thing is done
but I don't want to wait here until this
thing is done before I start the next
one I want to start all of them and then
wait for them to finish
you accomplish that using tasks
create task takes in a co-routine and
wraps it in a task object and schedules
that task on the event Loop but
importantly it does not await the task
right then and there this allows us to
create and schedule multiple tasks
before waiting on any of them
then we can use async io.weight to wait
on all of them and now when we run it
we see all three tasks are started
immediately then a second later they all
finish and it only took one second not
three because we were waiting on all
three tasks simultaneously this is still
just one python process and one python
thread we don't need multiple cores or
threads to wait for time to pass
the package will arrive the laundry will
finish and the cake will bake all
without any extra input from us we just
wait
if our co-routines returned any results
we could inspect the results like this
if there was an exception it would be
re-raised when we ask for the result
weight returns done tasks but also
pending ones this is because weight
supports a timeout and it's possible
that not all the tasks are done by the
time the timeout is over
but if you don't specify a timeout
pending should be empty
another way to do basically the same
thing is using async i o gather
this accumulates the results of the
tasks in a list it can even take
co-routines directly which is something
that weight can't do in that case it'll
automatically create tasks for them
you could catch any exceptions raised
with a try catch around this line or
specify return exceptions equals true to
just get the exceptions as elements of
the results list
and in Python 311 there's yet a third
way to do exactly the same thing
just like a normal with statement can
ensure that a file opened using open is
automatically closed this async with
task group ensures that all of the
created tasks are automatically awaited
I know this must be very jarring to have
three different ways to do exactly the
same thing I can hear murmurs of the Zen
of python even across the internet
but the reality of it is that
asynchronous programming in Python was
very much an afterthought
like it or not that's reality in Python
so we just have to deal with it just
make sure to keep up to date with best
practices it's one of the most rapidly
changing parts of python with each new
release
so enough with this syntax and the silly
example where I could just delete this
sleep statement let's get to the web
crawler
here's a basic but fully functional web
it takes an asynchronous client in this
case I'm using the HTTP X Library
we take some initial URLs to start our
crawl then this filter URL is just a
function that we're going to use to
filter out links that we don't want
and we'll take in the number of workers
this crawler should use which will
determine the number of simultaneous
connections it can use
and we'll put a limit on the total
number of pages to crawl 25 is a really
small limit but this is just for testing
purposes
we save the client
save the set of starting urls
we make a cue to hold the work that
needs to be done
scene will hold all the URLs we've seen
before to prevent us from crawling the
same one twice
and done will contain all the finished
crawls that were successful
we saw our filter function number of
workers and the limit on how many crawls
to do
then we initialize total which will keep
track of how many crawls we've done
everything is centered around this run
function
it's an async function that will crawl
until it's done
we start by putting our start URLs in
the queue
this is done in this on found links
function
whenever we find some links we compute
which ones we haven't seen before Mark
those as seen you could save things to a
database or file here but we're not
going to then for each new URL we put it
into our to-do queue
we do this in a separate function to
respect our limits whenever we put
something into the queue we add one to
the total if we're beyond our limit then
we don't put anything more into the
queue an async queue has a pretty
standard queue interface the main
methods being put and get
of course being an asyncue these are
async functions we didn't set a limit on
how big our queue can be but if we did
putting something into the queue might
require waiting until something else has
finished
anyway back to our run function
the effect of this is to put all of our
starting URLs into the queue then we use
a pretty common technique which is
creating a bunch of workers that all
simultaneously wait for work from the
queue each worker is just another
co-routine and we use create task to
schedule this many workers however we
don't wait on the workers we await on
what we actually care about the Q the Q
contains all the work that needs to be
done waiting for the queue to join is
the same as waiting for all the tasks to
be completed
as long as there's more tasks we want to
keep going but as soon as there's no
more work to do then we can stop in that
case we go through and cancel all the
workers cancel is a method that's
available on all Co routines that just
raises a canceled error inside the
co-routine
so what does each worker do they just
forever try to process one element in
the queue until they're canceled
processing an element is pretty
straightforward
get is also asynchronous and we might
have to wait in order to get work to do
if we do have to wait to get work that
means the queue is empty but that's not
the same as there being no work left to
do
that's because the cues join that we're
waiting on doesn't go based off of the
number of elements in the queue but
rather it goes off of whether the number
of elements taken out of the queue is
equal to the number of tasks that have
been marked complete so the general
pattern is
get work out of the queue
do the work and then Mark the work as
complete we use a try finally to ensure
that the task is always marked done no
matter whether there was an exception or
not this is important because if we ever
missed a task done the queue would never
join because it thinks that there's
still work in flight
as far as actually doing the work now we
finally get to something that's specific
to the crawler this whole run worker Q
stuff is a very common pattern so the
crawl is the first place that we
actually do something specific to our
crawler we try to crawl the URL and if
anything goes wrong we just pass if you
wanted to this would be the place to add
retry handling put the URL back into the
queue and keep note of how many times
you've tried we're going for a more
minimalistic approach
onto the crawl
I'm just outright sleeping for 0.1
seconds here this would be a good place
to do proper rate limiting you want to
make sure that you're not sending out
too many simultaneous connections both
in total and per domain our number of
workers limits the total number of
connections but we have nothing to limit
the number of connections per domain
in any case be nice rate limit yourself
oh and if you forget to rate limit
yourself this is a great way to get
yourself banned from all your favorite
websites many websites will
automatically ban your IP address if
they detect too many connections too
fast after rate limiting we use our
asynchronous client to go out and get
the URL
once you've got the HTML parse out the
links
mark them as found and then you're done
with that URL I left parse links as an
async function but really it's just
totally synchronous code
all I do is create this URL parser which
is a custom subclass of the built-in
HTML parser in Python
let's take a look at the parser
did you know python has a built-in HTML
parser
so please put away that attempt at using
a regular expression HTML is not a
regular language regular expressions are
not sufficient to parse HTML
all we do is override the handle start
tag from the class
there are other ways to look for links
but we're essentially just looking for a
href tags so if we see an a tag with an
ahref attribute then we go in and filter
our URL
if it passes the filter then we add it
to our set of found links just a note on
what this base thing is when you click
on a link where it takes you depends on
where you currently are
so the base is being used to track where
we currently are the filter URL function
we're using for this crawler isn't very
sophisticated
I wrote this URL filterer it just takes
allowed domains schemes and file types
then to filter the URL it parses where
the link would go based off of the base
and if the scheme is bad or if the
domain is bad or if the file type is bad
then we just return none otherwise we
return the normalized URL
you can really put in whatever you want
here those are just a few things I came
up with and that's it for the crawl we
got the response parse the links and
then on found links We'll add the new
ones back into our queue and then the
worker will just get the next element
and keep going eventually we'll either
crawl everything within our constraints
or hit the limit on the number of crawls
that we're willing to do either way the
queue will eventually empty the to do
join will finish and we'll cancel all
the workers who would otherwise be stuck
here waiting for more work
then all that's left to do is try it
let's make a URL filter I'm just going
to use my own domain as the only allowed
one and I'll only search links with HTML
PHP or no file extension
we use an async with to get a client for
our crawl
pass everything to the crawler with an
initial URL of the root of my website
and then await the crawler's run method
at the end we'll just print out the
results
and there you go it found all the pages
on my website
finally a quick tip when you're
debugging with co-routines
asyncio.run takes a debug flag if you
turn this on things will be slower but
you'll get way better error messages
if you're looking to test your
understanding then try some of these
exercises as homework
thank you to brilliant.org for
sponsoring this video
hone your algorithm skills with
Brilliance algorithm fundamental scores
where you can learn about classic
searching and sorting algorithms
Concepts like Big O notation and the
stable matching problem
or Branch out and find something new to
fit your taste brilliant has thousands
of interactive math science and computer
science lessons to help you learn
something new every single day
and there are more lessons on the way
every month so you're never going to run
out visit brilliant.org M coding or
click the link in the description to get
started with your free 30-day trial
today and if you'd like the first 200 of
my viewers to sign up for brilliant's
annual premium subscription will get 20
off that's brilliant.org M coding
as always thank you for watching and
thank you for making it to the end
asynchronous programming is a huge topic
so let me know if there's anything you'd
like me to cover as always thank you to
my patrons and donors for supporting me
see you next time